le président du conseil européen prête à
de dures négociations avant de recevoir
les 27 représentants de l'ue charles
michel a fixé le cap dans sa lettre
d'invitation
les regards seront tournés vers la
méditerranée ce soir un dîner sera
entièrement consacré aux relations
tumultueuses avec la turquie
notre objectif est de créer un espace
pour un dialogue constructif avec la
turquie afin de parvenir à la stabilité
et à la sécurité dans toute la région et
de garantir le plein respect de la
souveraineté et des droits souverains de
tous les états membres de l'union
européenne objectif principal est de
délimiter les zones d'exploration
d'hydrocarbures en méditerranée après
s'être retiré de la zone disputée
l'oru creis le navire turc de
prospection a jeté l'ancré au large
d'antalya un premier signe de
désescalade loin d'être suffisant pour
chypre l'autre partie concernée par
cette crise avec la turquie
le ministre de la santé les membres du
gouvernement compétent auront à
s'exprimer annoncer les décisions prises
et les ajustements
le gouvernement doit pouvoir prendre des
mesures additionnelles nécessaires en
fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie et
chaque mesure prise à un temps de vie de
15 jours parce que c'est le temps qui
permet de voir son efficacité
nicosie espère obtenir des garanties
d'autant que le pays bloque aujourd'hui
toutes sanctions ciblées contre la
biélorussie autres dossiers
problématiques pour les 27
le 21 septembre dernier les ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'ue eux
s'étaient réunis et n'avait pas trouvé
de consensus concernant la situation en
minsk la réélection du président
alexandre loukachenko est d'ailleurs au
programme de ce sommet européen
nous sommes aux côtés du peuple
bélarusse qui doit être libre sans la
moindre contrainte extérieure de choisir
son propre avenir le dialogue national
inclusif avec le soutien de l'oif c est
le seul chemin réaliste l'ol c'est eux
l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe
vendredi les dossiers kovy 19 et break
sites seront sur la table
750 milliards destinés à la relance post
pandémie devrait être évoqué un fonds de
solidarité qui ne fait toujours pas
l'unanimité au sein des pays membres
enfin les 27 de l'union européenne ne
pourront pas quitter bruxelles sans
faire un point sur la relation postgres
excite avec londres ce matin
la commission européenne a lancé une
procédure d'infraction contre le
gouvernement britannique
la raison un projet de loi controversé
portée ces dernières semaines par boris
johnson et adopté hier par les députés
britanniques
un texte qui permet au royaume uni de
revenir sur certaines dispositions
négociées avec l'union européenne
comme vous le savez nous avions invité
nos amis britanniques a retiré les
parties problématique de leur projet de
loi sur le marché intérieur avant la fin
du mois de septembre
ce projet de loi est par sa nature même
une violation de l'obligation de bonne
foi prévu dans l'accord de retrait en
outre s'il est adopté tel quel il sera
en totale contradiction avec le
protocole de l'irlande et l'irlande du
nord
le délai a expiré hier la nappe se
tenait un sommet européen crucial durant
lequel le président emmanuel macron ne
sera présent qu'aujourd'hui en raison
d'obligations en france vendredi